[Musique]
uniforme allemand et croix de lorraine
une association surprenante pendant le
second conflit mondial
elle les mois quand on sait que ces
jeunes hommes étaient des alsaciens
incorporés de force une simple photo qui
aurait bien pu leur coûter la vie et
illustre toute la complexité de la
situation des alsaciens et mosellans
durant la guerre longtemps ses formes de
résistance à l'ordre nazi sont restées
méconnues du grand public
en cause la situation particulière des
territoires annexés par leur âge
même si certains ont lutté activement
dès 1940 un contrôle totalitaire et une
répression féroce n'ont pas permis
l'émergence d' importante organisation
résistante ya pas eu de parachutages
d'armes chez nous par exemple n'y a pas
eu de maquis c'était différent vu que
l'alsace est d'ailleurs aussi la moselle
était annexé le fait on était considérés
comme appartenant au troisième reich
c'est vrai que la chape de plomb qui a
pesé sur les alsaciens donc
l'administration nazie
toutes les organisations nazis n'ont pas
laissé beaucoup de place pour une forme
de résistance et donc ça peut apparaître
comme une forme d'adhésion au régime
nazi
dès la mi juin 1940 le troisième reich
engage l'alsace et la moselle dans une
massification à marche forcée attendant
des populations une adhésion totale au
régime opposants et indésirables sont
expulsés beaucoup d'alsaciens reste
réfugié en france après la fin de l'
exode mai 1940
certains d'entre eux et créons des pages
glorieuses de l'histoire de la
résistance dans d'autres régions sur le
territoire alsacien aussi des actions de
résistance active sont menées
renseignements et sabotages mais pour
l'ensemble de la population
la simple contestation du nouvel ordre
nazis pouvait avoir des conséquences
terribles
ainsi durant toute la guerre la
résistance des alsaciens a pris d'autres
vous elle prend des formes plus passive
on va dire dans la dans la plupart des
cas c'est continuer à parler français en
famille parfois c'est un geste peut-être
le port du béret par les alsaciens parce
que l'alsacien était aussi interdite ce
sont des petites formes de résistance ou
ne pas se rendre à une réunion
une organisation nazie ça peut ça peut
prendre ce genre de formule 1 des formes
de résistance éloignées de celles qui
ont eu cours ailleurs une population
encadrés par l'appareil nazi et
l'enrôlement forcé de 130 mille jeunes
dans les armées allemandes
ainsi en 1945 le vécu des alsaciens et
mosellans ne cadre pas avec le récit
d'une france résistante ce qui permet de
dire à certains par exemple mais en
alsace vous étaient tous des [__]
moi je les ai entendus et d'autres ont
dû l'entendre et donc il faut pouvoir
avoir un argumentaire pour dire non
c'est pas vrai et je vais vous expliquer
la situation qui était complexe
il a fallu attendre près de soixante dix
ans pour que les contours de cette
résistance soit enfin étudier certes
beaucoup de documents restent à
exploiter mais l'aérien propose d'ores
et déjà un dvd ainsi qu'une exposition
pour présenter les résultats de trois
années de recherche un travail que vous
pourrez découvrir à la médiathèque
départementale du sundgau jusqu'au 23 7
ans parmi les missions de la médiathèque
départementale
il y à la transmission des savoirs pas
uniquement les savoirs littéraires mais
également des savoirs scientifiques et
les savoirs historique cette exposition
je les ai vus pour la première fois à
colmar dans le hall du conseil
départemental et m'a vraiment touchée
par ce qu'elle faisait écho à un travail
que j'ai fait dans ma propre commune la
commune de durmenach et à mon histoire
familiale
donc j'ai souhaité que cette exposition
puisse être rapatrié ici à la
médiathèque d'altkirch
parce que ici dans notre canton nous
avons quand même beaucoup de personnes
qui ont
vécu des choses fortes pendant la guerre
et notamment qui se sont qui sont partis
en suisse pour se soustraire alors le
roulement de l'armée allemande
proche de la suisse des réseaux de
passeurs s'organise très tôt dans le
sumo
objectif permettre l'évasion des
prisonniers de guerre et la fuite des
personnes menacées par les nazis à
partir de 1943 les départs s'accélère
c'est alors toute une partie de la
jeunesse qui cherche à fuir le travail
forcé et l'enrôlement dans l'armée les
déserteurs de la wehrmacht qu'on peut
aussi sur ces filières pour se mettre à
l'abri
on a eu plusieurs évasions très
importantes notamment la l'évasion de
riespach avec qu'on a appelée donc les
spams colonne où il y avait donc plus de
100 jeunes qui sont partis
évidemment les autorités les autorités
nazies ne vont pas ne vont pas laisser
passer ça et vont renforcer la
surveillance de la frontière
ce qui fait que deux jours plus tard on
a un groupe de jeunes des environs de
ballersdorf qui vont qui vont essayer de
passer et qui vont tomber par contre sur
une patrouille et qui vont être tous
certains arrêtés sur place même
tué lors d'une fusillade d'autres
arrêtés le lendemain chez eux et un seul
réussira finalement à passer en suisse
considérés comme des traîtres la
répression s'abat aussi sur les familles
des évadés les autorités nazies n'hésite
pas elle des portes systématiquement
toutes les familles le monument aux
morts de durmenach résume à lui seul
toute la tragédie qui s'est déroulée en
alsace ils sont inscrits les noms de
ceux qui ont perdu la vie sous les
couleurs françaises mais aussi en
portant l'uniforme allemand
ceux qui ont été tués pour avoir résisté
ou seulement tenté de fuir ceux qui ne
sont jamais revenus de la déportation et
enfin ceux juifs et tziganes victimes du
génocide
depuis peu les itinéraires de toutes ces
victimes sont connus et documentés
mais dans l'immédiate après-guerre
difficile d'écrire cette histoire la
période fut longtemps passé sous silence
par ceux là même qui l'avait vécu mon
père est parti en suisse ne m'a jamais
raconter cette histoire jusqu'à quelques
quelques petites années avant son décès
voilà c'est là où j'ai vraiment réalisé
ce que ces jeunes ont vécu et et je
pense que voilà il est important de d'en
parler ce sont des événements très très
difficile à raconter et
et il a fallu effectivement 40 ans à peu
près jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce que les
premiers osent en parler
les enfants n'ont jamais entendu parler
à leurs proches ont leur père par
exemple de cette question là par contre
moi je n'entends parler c'est une part
de responsabilité des anciens eux mêmes
mais pas uniquement il ya aussi le
contexte parce que dans le village on
veut pas on veut pas les questionner
surtout pas entendre ce qu'on puise pour
transmettre ces témoignages lus insee de
carspach vient de produire un
documentaire irène blanche
even ainsi que 16 autres sundgauviens
ils livrent leurs récits d'incorporation
de résistance d'exil ou encore comme
rené baumann des camps de concentration
lorsqu'on est rentré là dans la course
est ingrate 44% se commande à canossa
accueil et l'a dit ben entrés par la
porte ou ça vous allez tous sortir par
la fumée
un film pour conserver cette mémoire
mais aussi pour la transmettre aux
générations futures le sundgau sous
l'occupation sert ainsi de support
pédagogique dans les écoles mais il a
aussi projeté dans tout le département
preuve de l'utilité de ces témoignages à
l'issue de ces projections nombre
d'anciens se sentent enfin autorisé
raconté peut aussi bien il nous semblait
que
un dvd était un bon support pour faire
le travail de mémoire sur sur les
événements qui ont qui ont touché notre
notre région alsace
non
[Musique]
un travail d'autant plus important que
dans les années à venir la parole des
témoins finira par s'éteindre à tout
jamais pourtant aujourd'hui encore ces
récits demeure indispensable
c'est important qu'il y ait cette cette
transmission justement de ce travail de
mémoire de transmission de la mémoire et
le rôle du département et aussi de
travailler à destination de ces publics
cibles je veux dire notamment nos
collégiens pour nous qui avons grandi
dans une europe réconciliée loin des
ravages de la guerre connaître les
drames du passé permet d'éviter de les
reproduire
et peut-être aussi de mieux comprendre
ce qui se passe au delà de nos
frontières
[Musique]